[Musique]
contrarié jean luc mélenchon le député
de la france soumise s'est moqué de
l'accent toulousain d'une journaliste il
multiplie les dérapages en ce moment
écoutez les changes comme vous sont la
proie ya tant que moi dans mon coin que
les déboires judiciaires de francs et de
le pen passer d'une décadence de la
veille du week-end
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
qu'est-ce que celles diffusées vous
c'est quoi votre question je ne
comprends pas ce que l'époque
n'est pas de régler par ya six mois il
ya six mois qu'est ce que sonne de yahoo
excusez moi je ne m'en rappelle comme
mars où la trame des passionnés la
campagne électorale si ça fait beaucoup
non au mois de la réunion non madame
c'est parce que vous parmi six noms
français
fait compréhensible parce que moi ils
vont me dépasse
[Musique]